that's right a new show starring Kiefer
Sutherland and a little kid who doesn't
talk called touch don't be creepy touch
now touch is a new show set to premiere
on March 19th but the pilot episode
aired so I'm going to talk about that so
touch mainly revolves around Kiefer
Sutherland and his little kid yeah and
if you're expecting Kiefer to be the
Jack Bauer Power Hour aisle like I said
where's the Bob do you understand me
not like that Kiefer Sutherland plays
the father of an autistic kid who's
never spoken a word in his entire life
so in that it's a really intriguing
father-son type story about a father who
just can't connect with his child but on
the large scale scope of it it's a bit
bigger than that the show touch goes on
the philosophy that the world itself is
all constructed on a formula the
universe is made of precise ratios you
know the thread that connects everyone
together and connects events together
this leads to that that leads to that
and if anyone let's say Kieffer's kid
with autism could see that formula he
could then see how everything's
connected and then really cool stuff can
happen enter our show touch now touch is
created by the creator of heroes Tim
Kring if for nothing else that tells me
that touch will have a really intriguing
first season and seasons to Thor
cancelled not really wasn't a fan of
seasons two third floor of Heroes if you
remember Tim Kring was big on that and
hero season 1 Peter Petrelli would be
all like we're all connected so it looks
like Tim Cruise like all right we don't
need any superpowers but we're gonna
explore that concept we're gonna dive
headfirst into it and so that's pretty
much the premise of the show this
autistic kid sees the formula that ties
everyone and every event together and he
writes it all down and he starts doing
stuff that Kiefer Sutherland doesn't
really understand and so Kiefer kind of
catches on as to what's happening
especially actor is dialogue with Danny
Glover who pretty much breaks it down
for him your son sees everything
[Music]
the future of all connect and after he
knows what he's looking for he kind of
follows the path that his kids leading
for him and they do cool things example
if he follows the path that his kids
laying out for him and he's really
cryptic ways they can stop a plane crash
or something just an example I'm just
saying and before anyone says is like
that movie knowing which when I saw the
trailer for this I was like it's kind of
like the movie knowing it's not like the
movie knowing the movie knowing there's
more fatalistic it was someone who wrote
down times and places of catastrophes
and they were just gonna happen no
matter what it was just kind of like oh
yeah by the way this is gonna happen
touch deals with someone who sees like
the matrix
of life and then through that they can
like avert catastrophe and it's not just
like this one thing it's not like oh
this one catastrophe that they're
averting you see other people throughout
the world you're like what do they have
to do with this and in the end the
actions and events that Kieffer and his
kid are doing in this one episode will
affect a few people throughout the world
when you see it you can't help but just
be like that's really cool this show
does a really good job at showing that
the thread that ties everything together
is it's a big spiderweb it's not like
one linear thing and it does a really
good job of putting math science
spirituality and religion all under one
roof and that's really cool after seeing
the pilot episode of touch I want to see
the next episode I want to see the
season this looks like it could be one
of the more intriguing shows that I'll
see on TV and yes it is on Fox so Fox
don't cancel the show if it ends up
sucking and yes sure but as for right
now don't let it get a couple seasons in
if this show sticks to the premise that
it has it should be really good and
although the show doesn't premiere until
March 19th you can check out the pilot
episode on Comcast on demand or on Fox
com so good knock yourself out so have
you seen the pilot episode of touch what
did you think about it I really want to
know what you guys thought about this
show so comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you